good morning John so around the time
when a single Bitcoin started to be
worth like thousands of dollars you
started emailing me every once in a
while saying you're pretty sure that
sometime in the distant past somebody
sent us a Bitcoin and I told you that
that was ridiculous and impossible and
to stop having weird dreams and then the
price of a Bitcoin jumped up to $10,000
and you email me again and you're like
Hank I'm pretty sure somebody gave us a
Bitcoin and I told you that you were
wrong and if anything somebody sent us a
dogecoin which isn't worth a lot and
then a single Bitcoin became worth
$15,000 and you stopped bothering with
me and instead did a systematic search
of every email we had received since the
beginning of Bitcoin and then John you
found that a nice person named Sean had
in 2014 sent us a Bitcoin almost an
entire Bitcoin we had to recreate an old
email address to get access to that
Bitcoin it was a bit of a to-do but at
the end of the process I logged into
coinbase and there was $15,000 that we
didn't know we had and then we sold it
immediately and then donated the
proceeds to Partners in Health so thank
you Sean this is very strange and
there's a lot to cover when it comes to
Bitcoin and while the technology of
Bitcoin is super amazing and we made a
scishow video about it and you can watch
it I want to talk about one of the more
boring mundane aspects of Bitcoin which
is how something that cost Sean a
hundred dollars became worth fifteen
thousand dollars where did that value
that actual literal money come from all
the times in our minds when we talk
about financial markets we imagine them
as being like either magic or like
invisible hand dish things are happening
like our Bitcoin became worth fifteen
thousand dollars because the value of
Bitcoin increased but of course that's
gibberish basically like saying it
rained more because more water came out
of the sky
my Bitcoin became worth fifteen thousand
dollars the moment someone else bought
another Bitcoin on the open market for
fifteen thousand dollars and not only
mine everyone's and when I saw my
Bitcoin I sold it to someone who bought
it with money a lot of money when they
paid for it they set the price for every
Bitcoin in that moment and of course the
same thing goes in the way down if
suddenly there are more people selling
Bitcoin than buying Bitcoin will start
selling their Bitcoin at lower prices
and suddenly every
Bitcoin that exists is worth less money
this is the way that financial markets
work and it's pretty weird the only
thing that decides how much a share and
Google is worth is the most recent
purchase of Google stock if suddenly no
one in the world would buy a share in
Google for more than a dollar Google
shares would be worth a dollar
it's just humans deciding whether to buy
or sell to other human but the value of
Google stock is based on Google's
ability to make money which has some
consistency to it to some extent it's
additionally based on people's belief
that it will be able to make more money
in the future a bitcoins value on the
other hand is mostly based on an
uncertain prediction that at some point
in the future lots of people will use
bitcoins as currency and that's a bet on
a future that no one can accurately
predict and also that I can't really
even advocate for but partners in health
I know is adding value to the world so
I'd rather them have my Bitcoin because
Partners in Health does amazing work
with passion and intelligence and if you
want a wonderful way to spend a half an
hour or so I've linked to an amazing
article about Partners in Health in the
description thank you for sharing that
article with me it's changed the way I
think about a lot of stuff and thank you
for finding our Bitcoin I still cannot
believe that you were right I'll see you
on Tuesday
hey everybody two things first I did the
nerdfighteria census analysis it's it's
over on Hanks Channel it's quite long
and very interesting and number two
until the end of January you can join
dftba as new pin subscription the dftba
pin pals this is the first pin shipping
is free everywhere in the world the
second one hasn't been printed yet but
it looks like this and the third one
I've been working on its Mars Pathfinder
which the first rover on Mars an
extremely important object in my life
there's a limited number of openings in
the subscription Club so that we don't
make too many or too few pins so go sign
up links in the description